nie wieder opfer ein schöner start titel
doch über den feeder fetisch möchte ich
nun mit sexologin jana welt sprechen
guten abend frau welt ja die erste frage
natürlich woher kommt so ein fetisch und
wie entsteht er dass man seine freundin
messen will
ja ich glaube man muss vielleicht erst
mal erklären was ist das überhaupt so
ein feature fetisch das ist ja nicht
etwas was also alle tage irgendwo
begegnet
und es ist ja auch nicht einmal ein sehr
seltener fisch da geht es darum dass es
auf der einen seite einen wiedergibt und
auf der anderen seite einen feed die
unterschiede ist derjenige der die
nahrung aufnimmt und wieder ist
derjenige der die nahrung weil sie dem
anderen verabreicht aber da muss man
wissen dass der lustgewinn nicht daran
liegt den anderen zu füttern sondern
eben sich daran so erfreuen wie der
andere dicker und dicker wird und man
geht davon aus dass gerade viele eben
eine vorliebe haben für besonders runde
formen ja es gibt ja auf der anderen
seite auch menschen die einen fetisch
für ganz dünne menschen und so gibt es
eben auch den feature fetisch der
genauso wie männer vor allen dingen eben
lust daran finden ihre frau zu füttern
und zu füttern unterfüttern
sie haben gerade gesagt männer vor allem
gibt es denn auch frauen die ihre männer
füttern
ja also ich hab das jetzt mal
recherchiert weil ich hab' ich habe
hauptsächlich männer gefunden die diesen
fetisch und ich hatten aber auch ein
fall entdeckt wo es tatsächlich eine
frau gibt aber grundsätzlich kann man
schon so anders der fita fetisch bei den
männern liegt wenn man in so einer
toxischen beziehung ich hoffe das kann
man so sagen sonst korrigieren sie mich
bitte sie sind die expertin
wenn man sich in so einer toxischen
beziehung ja befindet wie kommt man dann
dort wieder raus also da muss man eben
das sagen sie schon ganz richtig da muss
man eben gucken ist es denn tatsächlich
toxisch oder ist es etwas was vielleicht
doch beide mögen und möchten weil in
ganz vielen ich sag mal beziehungen mit
einem fetisch finden diese sachen auch
ein konzert statt wenn man muss sich
vorstellen dass er wahnsinnig schwierig
sein partner davon zu überzeugen dass er
was essen soll die ganze zeit ja da
braucht es ja auch von dem vieh ein
einverständnis aber immer dann und das
sagen sie
so korrekt wenn es etwas ist was ich
nicht möchte oder wenn es etwas ist was
mir überhaupt nicht mich nicht sexuell
erregt und ich mache es nur für meinen
partner dann finde ich muss man entweder
mit seinem partner das muss man sowieso
ganz klar sprechen und sagen passt auch
hier ist meine grenze ich möchte das
nicht weitermachen oder ich muss mir
professionelle hilfe so ganz klar
aber kommen wir jetzt noch als letzte
frage zu dem fall von aline bachmann ich
mal ein bisschen 200 kilo also es ist ja
nicht mehr gesund das heißt selbst wenn
man damit der chor ist sollte man nicht
trotzdem aus seiner beziehung probieren
sich zu lösen wie würden sie das
beispiel von aline bachmann einschätzen
na ja also es gibt auch ganz viele fälle
wo eben beide damit einverstanden waren
dass da eine so dick wird dass es sich
nicht mehr bewegen kann bei frau
bachmann war es natürlich so dass es
nicht mehr im konsens war oder sie
wahrscheinlich nicht in der lage war
ihre grenzen zu setzen und hat dann auch
erst sehr spät sich vielleicht hilfe von
außen und gesuchte ja absolut richtig
das ist dann in toxischen beziehungen
eine ist nicht mehr möchte und es auch
nicht schafft da rauszukommen und dann
ist es ganz wichtig dass man irgendwo
hingeht und sagt hey ich brauche hilfe
oder in ihrem fall soll ich das
verstanden waren ja auch die eltern die
ihr beiseite gestanden haben und das ist
ganz toll dass sie es geschafft hat und
auch super also sind buch gibt wo eben
leute die betroffenen sind nachlesen
können vielen dank frau welche ich finde
es großartig dass es bücher gibt um
frauen aus toxischen so würde ich es
wenigstens bezeichnen herauszuhelfen
vielen lieben dank für das gespräch und
ihre expertise haben sie noch einen
schönen abend
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren